[Music]
some things just go well together salt
and pepper
peanut butter and jelly french toast and
room service hillary clinton and
ignoring serious sex abuse allegations
during 1990s Hillary Clinton defended
her husband in the face of them in the
2000 she was a close confidant of Harvey
Weinstein's her husband meanwhile flew
around on Jeff Jeffrey Epstein's plane
but in 2018 Hillary Clinton pivoted
completely but Cavanaugh you'll remember
was accused there without any evidence
of being a sexual predator and Hillary
Clinton said his accuser had to be
believed look I I watched as much of her
testimony as I could I found her very
credible I found her
willingness to say I don't remember that
but I remember this to be very
convincing
well you know things change the only
constant is change and the political
calculations of these questions has
changed completely all of a sudden so
Hillary Clinton has rediscovered the
value of skepticism and due process why
two words Tara Reid that's a former
Biden staffer who alleges that Biden
sexually assaulted her
no not sexually harassed but assaulted
physically today Hillary Clinton didn't
just endorse the man accused of that by
a former staffer Joe Biden she gushed
about Biden's character watch this we
need a leader a president like Joe Biden
I also know a lot about Joe the person
I've seen him up close and personal now
for many years we have a lot of the same
values in common the kind of compassion
and caring that we need from our
president and which Joe Biden has been
exemplifying throughout his entire life
you're probably too transfixed by
Hillary Clinton to notice the guy next
to her Joe Biden finally fell asleep a
couple times in the middle of that short
oration poor Joe Biden Hillary's
probably staying up late right now
figuring how she can snatch the
nation from him but the point stands she
doesn't believe all women jean-pierre Oh
does she hos justice with Janine she
joins us tonight judge thanks so much
for coming on so this is almost too easy
but I I have to get your view of this
Hillary Clinton has pivoted once more
and now she thinks we should pause
before judging you know Hillary Clinton
endorsing Joe Biden when he's being
accused of as you say not sexual
harassment but sexual assaults it's like
the kiss of death
the woman is literally a standard bearer
the magnet the enabler for sexual
predators whether it had to do with her
husband it was credibly accused of
raping would Anita Broderick who had a
busted lip disheveled clothes and made
an immediate outcry or her laughing
about the rapists who raped a
twelve-year-old into a coma or her
emails that were found on Anthony
Weiner's laptop or Jeffrey Epstein are
hanging out with Weinstein when everyone
in Hollywood knew what was going on did
I go on but let me just say this about
her this woman is a woman who does not
stand for women and for for her right
now to endorse Joe Biden is really to
ignore what all of the me2 movement has
been talking about when they yelled at
us during the Brett Kavanaugh hearings
all women need to be believed except if
they're Republican or except that
they're choosing a Democrat let's talk
about Brett Kavanaugh and Tara Tara Reid
Tara Reid of choosing Joe Biden I come
to this Tucker as a prosecutor and as a
judge I started a sex crimes unit in the
DA's office I know this business very
well she Tara Reid made an immediate
outcry a recent outcry is a
contemporaneous report and it holds a
lot of weight in the criminal courtroom
in a sex offense case and what that
means is that it is it is admissible
evidence and the jury is allowed to find
the victim more credible if she made an
outcry Tara Reid made an outcry to her
mother her brother her friend and we
found out yesterday her neighbor who
supports Joe Biden but who says Tara
Reid doesn't lie Tara Reid also made a
recent outcry to the people in
Senate this happened to her when she was
working for Joe Biden and when she made
the complaint to three people about Joe
Biden pushing her up against a wall in
the Senate when no one else was around
pulling up her skirt and putting his I'm
not going to get graphic here but
sexually abusing her they moved her away
from where she had been working in the
Senate office to a room with no windows
in all three interns that she oversaw as
a supervisor can attest to the fact that
she was abruptly taken away as her as
their supervisor and finally we have
documentary evidence that she worked
with Joe Biden
we have Senate records and the mother
even though the mother passed complained
to Larry King we have that evidence in
1993 when this happened now when it came
to Cavanaugh Christine Blasi Ford didn't
know the date time place or a year and
she not only didn't have any
corroboration there was negative
corroboration and what I mean by that is
people that christine blazing for it
said were with her when Brett Kavanaugh
assaulted her said no we weren't so this
is just politics pure unadulterated
politics it's about power supporting
people who you want to be empowered has
nothing to do with women and protecting
women in the system was nothing with
women
I'm not much of a feminist I would never
hang around with Harvey Weinstein and
Bill Clinton it really tells you a lot
about her judging thank you for that
good to see you tonight okay